you asked me about the nature of our
relationship I needed to know who I was
talking to where you my friend across
the fire who are
you and if I can't answer that
question it's terribly difficult to
recruit for a secret service you're
looking for somebody who's a bit bad but
at the same time loyal there's a
type and I fitted perfectly
in your Memoir you say none of it's true
it's as I imagined
[Music]
it when I was in MI6 it wasn't enough
for me so what I did was reinvent the
secret world and fill my own people with
[Music]
it why is betrayal an important concept
to you it has a long family
background writing is a journey of
self-discovery I see my own life as a
succession of Embraces and
escapes maybe this is an interrogation
maybe I am self deceived I don't know
but I'll answer any question you wish me
to answer as truthfully as I
[Music]
can